what's going on guys this is Rob first
things first I promise you I have not
given up on life even though I may look
like that I I just jumped up relatively
recently and I figured I want to go in
and get this recorded and get it
uploaded sometime today and it's kind of
weird because I don't like really doing
you know three uploads a day because I
feel like a burns people out but we'll
get to we'll get two uploads here in a
second ah first things first we got it
we got to address the elephant in the
room and I hate to be the one to do this
well we got to talk about the elephant
in the room
um spider-man you guys thought I was
gonna give you bad news huh nope that
spider-man trailer looks amazing fanboy
or fangirl if you're a girl that trailer
looks so badass okay so so here's the
deal so we saw the spider wings alright
we saw the web wings rather and I feel
like I feel like Marvel's pulling our
ears I think that people like they're
though like hey guys aren't you excited
for those web wings they're gonna be the
big draw for the movie right right nope
I see the big draw I think like the big
reveal and the movie that's going to be
the iron spider costume now for those
you guys who don't know the iron spider
costume is it's really like spider-man's
own personal Iron Man suit and the sense
of Tony Stark designed to form and if
you like camouflage and had these little
appendages that come out and does all
kinds of really really cool stuff but
it's designed so like enhanced Spider
Man's existing abilities I think it was
introduced as part of the lead up to
Civil War one I'm pretty sure that was
the case either way it was really really
badass it was really really exciting but
um I think that's gonna be the the huge
thing but usually the other thing to the
Spider Man I think is a fresh influx in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
you know as much as I love those movies
and you guys know I love the Marvel
movies and I like some of the DC we used
to um I hate the way that that sounds um
it is
the only real humor we've had is like 25
the only real like character with
consistent humor that we've had is 20
story we get little bits here and there
from Captain America a little bit here
and there from The Incredible Hulk or
Thor but Tony Stark's like the main
humor though probably is he has a very
sarcastic sense of humor and so you know
I think that having Tom Holland as
spider-man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe will add some much-needed humor
because you know he's very he's these
vibrant he's young he's a fresh new
character you know it'll be really
really I think it'll be really fun in
terms of how he relates to everybody
else in the Avengers because remember
for him this is all brand-new stuff like
it's all just it's crazy you know all
these these adventurous new things that
are going on right now so um I think
it'll be a really great a really great
experience having said that make sure
you guys like this video I hate to
address like like for real address in
the elf in the room YouTube's new
algorithm requires that you get a whole
lot of life's in order for videos to
succeed in it con sucks you got a big
form whatever if you want to go on dates
you got to work within the confines of
YouTube it's you know it's just the way
the game is played you know for those of
you guys who want the girl on YouTube
keep that in the back of your head
always do Google searches and always see
what people are doing in their videos
because they'll tell you what YouTube
requires you to do in order to succeed
on a YouTube channel I get a lot of
requests a lot of people ask how do you
grow on YouTube um really it's just
there's there's no formula it's just one
of those weird things like you know
when it comes to how you choose
algorithm works every youtuber is just
flying by the seat of their pants
they're just trying to figure it out as
they go along so it's one of those those
crazy things but um the other thing too
is make sure you guys have notifications
turned on so you guys don't miss videos
people been asking me how they're how
come my videos not showing up how can
we're not getting notification stuff
like that if you look down by the sub
button there'll be a little bell if the
bells got two lines on top of it it
means that you guys are getting
notifications if it does not have two
lines and it's just a little bell it
means you're not getting notifications
so make sure those notifications are
turned on and and yeah anyway so amazing
spider-man is gonna be is gonna be
badass I mean I'm I'm I'm extremely
excited for me let's be honest this is
the most anticipated trailer of the year
for the most anticipated movie of next
year cuz I'll be honest as much as I
loved Captain America's Civil War it
ain't got nothing on spider-man my hype
for spider-man movie as soon as it was
announced as soon as we
the Tom Holland was gonna be joining the
spider-man or joining the Marvel Civil
War roster and as soon as we found out
he was getting a movie next year but it
was gonna be in the summer we were like
okay his trailers gonna drop sometime
this year and that's what I'm looking
forward to the my what's what a time to
be a comic book fan there was a time not
that long ago when being a comic book
fan with something you kept to yourself
and you had to sit at the weird table
and you had a sort of a table by
yourself and either lunch alone but now
everybody wants to know about committers
now you're the cool kid now people are
like hey like like tell me about
vitamins like what do you know about
spider-man
you look cool kid now guys you are the
cool kids so it's a very it's a very
exciting time to be to be a comic book
fan but yeah it's an ignore the mess
back here I'm in the middle of cleaning
up ignore the mess are sad but um but
anyway so it hopefully you guys can tell
I'm really really excited about this I'm
really gassed up next year can't come
fast enough because it's next next
summer is I mean like next year is it's
just gonna explode with comic book
movies I mean we got Thor Ragnarok we
got the Justice League we have guardians
of the galaxy we got spider-man um we
have Logan I think comes out I think
it's the first movie of next year I
think Logan comes out in March something
along those lines it's very exciting
time um I'm really really happy about
this but anyway guys I'm gonna go ahead
and wrap this video up and yeah I will
catch you all later please